ich glaube da habe ich so das habe ich
genommen und dachte so das ist schon
mein heimlicher favorit zumindest vom
namen her
ritter sport weiß und chris und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video helium
natürlich geht es gut heute nach gar
nicht mal so langer zeit ich habe es im
letzten paar schon angekündigt also im
letzten part alle sorten von einem
produkt aus dem supermarkt dass ich auch
noch alle ritter sport sorten auf euren
wunsch gekauft habe die ware im angebot
55 cent pro schokolade da habe ich
natürlich zugeschlagen und ich habe
versucht alles zu kaufen und ich habe
alle gekauft außer vier oder fünf
sozialen wieder bei über 20 gewesen und
dann das hätte ich nicht in einem video
gepackt ich habe halt einfach die
genommen die mich am meisten ansprechen
machst du deswegen ich will sagen will
aber nicht lange wenn ihr sagt macht das
auch mit dem und dem produkt dann
schreibe es in die kommentare
doch nach oben und starken jetzt einfach
so hier also wir haben wir 15 stück also
15 sorten wie zum beispiel waffen wie
noch nie gesehen oder das hier himbeer
joghurt klingt schon mal ganz gut ich
würde gern mal kommentieren was macht er
lieber maker oder ritter sport
was magst du lieber gar weiß nicht so
also ich bin jetzt nicht so ein schoko
freak aber ich würde schon sagen dass
ritter sport so ein bisschen
wintersport ist etwas für ältere und
milka so für die jugend oder wintersport
hat irgendwie so noch ausgefallenere
kreationen finde ich lass mir starten
oder gucken was da kommt ja ja die stadt
einfach jemand dem standardmodell muss
ich das probiere einfach dann ein ort
mit acht punkte weil es habe ich bei mir
auch so gemacht nein du musst alle
probieren
das ist ja kein gast da ich weiß ja wie
das schmeckt ja egal
jakob finde ich schmeckt besser als
milka alpenmilch oder vollmilch heißt
ihr könnt ruhig aber trotzdem acht von
zehn so fangen wir ganz normal an acht
von zehn punkte habe ich beim kauf
gemacht und damit ich jetzt mal auf
diese kreation hier gespannt
als erstes haben wir ritter sport café
splitter ich mag café mittlerweile echt
gerne aber das weg kann werden sehen ich
kann jetzt aber auch nicht das ganze
stück essen weil sonst haben wir am ende
wieder habe ich eine ganze tafel gestern
das ist so fiel es mir schlecht
[Musik]
der erste geschmack war grausam
dann wird es ein bisschen besser 15
danke drunter also jetzt wird's auf
jeden fall interessant rom taube nuss
ist da ist alkohol bekommen wir wieder
so ein ding appel 2
ja ich weiß habe ich mir schon gedacht
somit etwas verpflegung kann es nicht
weitergehen
bin gespannt um trauer cola & rau
benutzt oder das riecht richtig erholt
das war jetzt wieder also erstmal
geschmack war richtig schlimm das wetter
durch marketing so aber kriegt trotzdem
nur drei von vielen kalorien mehr geht
nicht
jetzt mache weiter mit joghurt wahr das
hab' ich glaube ich früher richtig gerne
gegessen
kanntest du kannst du aufhören die hat
noch immer so eine sonder längliche
verpackung und da waren ganz klein drin
also ich glaube ich gut mache ich
vielleicht gerne deswegen probieren wir
auch mal ein ganzes stück
[Musik]
schon echt lecker reicht das für den 19
ich gebe meine neun von zehn also es ist
mehr gut ich glaube bei milka was
ähnlich da hat auch milch joghurt auf
jeden fall hat er irgendwie sowas
gewonnen checkt das video gerne ab falls
das noch nicht gesehen habt neun von
zehn okay als nächstes haben die ritter
sport knusper keks kenne ich noch so das
ist ja auf jeden fall was leckeres so
esther stahl drin
[Musik]
auch 19 ist auch mir gut ich glaube da
habe ich so das habe ich genommen und
dachte so das ist schon mein heimlicher
favorit zumindest vom namen her
ritter sport weiß und chris kannst du
dieses kloster zeugs davon was so
richtig so prickelt dem mund das kommt
auch noch
also ich persönlich ich feiere weiße
schokolade voll so aber das ist auch
keine 10 19 und leighton von 10 sieht
das schön aus sondern vor allem man kann
man die namen lesen sie haben ja schon
recht daher so wie das vor lukas also
machte ich nie gerne das habe ich früher
auch schon öfter mal gegessen aber
machte ich nie richtig das ist mir
einfach zu krass schokolade aber
geschmäcker verändern sich auch immer
noch so ist jetzt nicht richtig schlecht
aber dann schmeckt so wie als würde mir
davon schlecht werden wenn ich zu viel
essen und deswegen gibt es von mir
sechs von zehn punkte ok kommen wir als
nächstes zu ritter sport knusperflocken
dass das was ich meinte das prickelt dem
und bist du dir sicher dass ich
irgendwie aus wie cornflakes na ja wir
werden sehen
[Musik]
aber er tut aber das sei ja ich weiß
auch nie also wer hat nicht so nichts
was mich irgendwie richtig umgehauen hat
das ist sehr schade deswegen kann ich
hier leider auch einen neuen fonds ihren
punkte geben
man man man schwierig ich hab so einen
anstrengenden job kommt als nächstes zu
ritter sport bunte vielfalt cacau muss
die sorte kann ich auf jeden fall noch
nicht genau so wie alle restlichen die
wir noch haben ach so doch das kenne ich
noch so glaube ich aber also joghurt
kenne ich das weiß ich nicht mehr da ist
halt wirklich so cacau drin man das ist
so schwierig heute also schmeckt schon
geil aber schmeckt ähnlich wie dieses
logo zeigt
und da würden wir auch schnell von
schlecht werden deswegen kann ich darauf
wenigstens hingeben oder ist das dorf
das ding ist das denn jetzt alles von
neun von zehn war es schmeckt halt echt
gut aber es ist nicht so wie bei diesen
sorten wo ich dann als zehn von zehn
parteien die mich halt direkt umhauen
weißt du wir hatten zum beispiel
letztens bei joghurt mit der ecke diesen
diesen joghurt mit pistazien und so der
halt wirklich kaspar oder müller milch
und hier
neun von zehn na ja mach mal weiter hier
haben wir karamell hughes kenn ich nicht
also das scheint auch neu zu sein
nur du magst du komm mit ich bin ein
richtiger was was sag ich ja mit
karamell vorher die großen stücke sind
die manchmal größeren manchmal kleiner
[Applaus]
sieben von zehn
ich muss auch wenn ich sagen ich kann
jetzt nicht mehr deutlich weiter essen
weil ich führe schon das ist nicht gut
aber lassen wir hier mit weitermachen
himbeer joghurt nummer das sieht auf
jeden fall stylish aussieht verpackung
wird am heftigsten
[Musik]
deutschland brauche man das ist so
schwierig was auch ich gebe es 10 9 von
10 punkten aber es ist bis jetzt die
beste 9 prozent aber es ist keine zehn
von zehn mann schokobraun ii hat sich
auch lecker an so ich weiß nicht was
haben wir hier noch erdbeer joghurt und
waffe
da bin ich gespannt auf ritter sport
waffeln also hier ist halt wirklich
anscheinend eine waffel zwischen
ihr wisst ja schon was eingeordnet wird
sieben von zehn mann das ist so eine
scheiße was solche als letztes machen
das würde geld machen ich kann mich
nicht daran erinnern dass ich jemals der
joghurt probiert habe ja ich möchte auf
jeden fall richtig gut aber wenn ich im
hinter der neuen fonds ergeben haben
wieso soll ich denn jetzt 10
neben klar rp rund hinweise unterschied
aber es schmeckt eigentlich fast gleich
hat mir schon mal ein erstes video wo
wir keine zehn von zehn verteilt habe
ich glaube er hat mir schon
ich weiß wenn man nicht mehr welches das
jetzt auch noch weit von 10
und zu guter letzt schokobraun
vielleicht weil es ja jetzt noch aus ich
weiß es nicht
[Musik]
ich möchte eigentlich einfach nur noch
schokolade kann ich auf keinen fall mit
sieben von zehn gehen das geht nicht
acht von zehn muss ich leider hier im
alten mich anschließen
das gibt es doch gar nicht haben keine
szenen von sehen ich glaube es hat mir
noch nie aber wenn du mir jetzt was
empfehlen würde hier die neuen die sind
alle gut wenn du nur eine hättest ja
welche würdest du mir empfehlen falls du
bist ein traumlos für die man ja gut das
wars oder leute ich weiß nicht ich bin
nicht so ganz zufrieden aber wir sehen
uns morgen 19 uhr wieder wenn ihr noch
irgendwelche anderen in denen für essens
formate hat schreibt in die kommentare
weil ich bin gott stand nahm aus titeln
für neue konzepte das war's instagram
alex wie hart ein